do you know anybody living who expressly
consents to the existence of the
government and extent and consents to
what it does my rights your rights are
integral to our humanity the government
can't take them away by majority vote
I'm Nicolas be with Reason TV today
we're talking with Judge Andrew
Napolitano he is with Fox News he's the
senior judicial analyst and the author
of many books and a great friend to
freedom and to reason thanks for talking
with especially Jinping with Inuk 2016
election it's about - you know stuffs
getting real what do you see as the
major stakes in this game there's you
know Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump is
the major party candidates are either of
them acceptable as president of the
United States long complex question for
from me working at at Fox News being
aware of mrs. Clinton's criminal
behavior having a personal financial
relationship with Donald Trump I might
add the Donald Trump that I know
personally does not resemble the Donald
Trump that you see on the glacier trail
what is really on a piece of real estate
with others that he managed okay and the
people that owned this with me loved him
because the value of it keeps going up
and and he is worth what we pay his
management company so what's the play
he's a falling businessman or property
manager listen this can this particular
case he's president well the the issue
as I see it
is the likely demise of constitutional
government as we understand it as we
have come to understand it it says
whether it's Clinton or Trump correct
correct Nick because they each believe
in their own version of big government
neither of them recognizes the natural
law restraints on government neither of
them recognizes the constitutional
restraints on government they each
believe that they can use the powers of
government to build their version of big
government whether it's sort of an
economic egalitarianism that Donald
Trump reaches or whether it's a Bernie
Sanders redistribution of wealth which
Hillary now embraces so how does
this happen I mean because these you
know these they didn't come out of
nowhere I mean they are the Republican
and Democratic nominees what's going on
with the parties in America because it's
it's not just the individuals the
Democratic Party has continued its march
hard to the left which you know I mean
in my view it's been on the left side
for a long time going back to FDR and
LBJ accelerated it and George McGovern
almost took it over the cliff and that
tends to move the center a little bit to
the left which gives Republicans cover
for their own version of big government
I mean stated candidly I have as much
objection to Paul Ryan as I do to Nancy
Pelosi because Ryan just keeps churning
out legislation that the White House
wants because there's a little snippet
in there that pleases country-club
Republicans but there's nothing in there
that pleases Jeffersonians people who
are worried about how the federal
government can do all these things that
are not justified by the Constitution
and why the constitutional argument
seems to be made on Fox News at Reason
magazine at Freedom Fest in an academic
circles but rarely rarely on the floor
of the Congress is there any way that
that is going to be reeled back because
I can remember a period I guess in the
90s when the Lopez decision that reeled
back some of up ended the federal
gun-free school zone act yes and I can
remember people like Glenn Reynolds the
you know who runs is funded law
professor University of Tennessee said
this is the beginning of the red courts
court they were actually reeling in the
Commerce well I agreed with professor
Reynolds when he said that it hasn't
turned out as well as he and I and those
of us are on this side of things would
have liked it but this Lopez decision
which which invalidated the gun-free
zones because the it was written in the
base of the Commerce Clause and the
Supreme Court said carrying a gun
outside of school is not a commercial
activity it's a criminal activity but
first time since the since the New Deal
that the Supreme Court has rolled back
something that the Congress did on the
basis of the
the concert is that a sign then that the
Supreme Court you know and this is
something that people talk about when
they say oh well you know what like
Hillary is awful at least Trump would
give us would give us Republican or
conservative judges but the court really
isn't that powerful then right and and I
mean we need people who believe in
limited government constitutional
government we need those people were to
be to be on the court because unless the
Congress is filled with people like Ron
and Rand Paul it will continue to give
away the people's money and it will
continue to trample the restraints
imposed upon it by the by the
Constitution whether it's a Democrat
version of great government or a
Republican version of here is one of the
things that really I think splits you
with a lot of your colleagues at Fox but
also libertarians from conservatives
talk about how you take libertarian
principles into things like foreign
policy and immigration in a way that
oftentimes conservatives tend to be
against immigration and they tend to be
for foreign intervention what's the arc
alright the reason I'm smiling is
because I ever get as much heat from any
from Fox fans and Fox viewers about
anything as I do about immigration
so to true libertarians and this is not
even all libertarian rights you know but
to true Thomas Aquinas natural law
loving libertarians that our rights come
from our humanity you have the right to
travel wherever you want which includes
across a border so I am unabashedly
unapologetically an open borders person
if I want my cousin's from Florence to
come and live in my home or if I want to
rent an apartment for them to stay here
quite frankly it's none of the federal
government's business now that doesn't
mean they should qualify for the type of
largesse that the gut rod gives away but
the government doesn't have the right to
stop them because of their nationality
or their place of order that doesn't
work very well with conservative no no
no it doesn't work well nor nor does to
get back to the first part of your
question the libertarian view of a
foreign policy which is the
non-aggression principle which is that
that aggression the powers of war can
only be used for defensive purposes
or when it is it is certain that they
will be needed for defensive purposes
but the idea of dislodging a tyrant or
the idea of changing borders national
borders in the Middle East by using the
American military is antithetical to
basic non-aggression principle so how do
you feel about Gary Johnson in this
election and more you know what we're
seeing is a third term entering American
politics you know we've got a
conservative Republican kind of a
liberal Democrat kind of and we have a
libertarian libertarian is this a good
time okay I'm not so sure that Donald
Trump is a conservative Republican I as
well as I know him right and as much as
I like him personally I do not know
where he stands on a lot of these issues
I was extremely dismayed I've said this
already in public that he went on
abortion from the mother should be
punished too maybe we should be a
pro-choice party that's 180 degrees and
and from my position at Fox we we are
not supposed to say I'm voting for this
person but it is clear that my views and
it is clear that libertarian views are
far more consistent with Gary Johnson's
I don't think there's a libertarian bone
and mrs. Clinton's body and I don't know
of one in Donald Trump's body or its
bizarrely
this organization called libertarians
for Trump one of the founders of it is a
dear dear friend of mine professor
Walter block at Loyola University in the
world he is so libertarian that I often
say to groups I am wherever I go the
most libertarian person in the room
except when Walter block is there so now
I can say that without the exception
because he's he thinks that Trump will
save us what is his case for Trump hood
that the lesser of two evils that so do
you think libertarian ideas are
ascendant right now in America I mean
Johnson and well they're doing well in
the polls that the phrase seems to be
catching on people are looking for an
alternative is that alternative
libertarian the answer is yes they are
ascendant and yes that is the
alternative and it will draw young
people from all across the board it will
draw a Bernie Sanders people who will
not get their their redistribution but
they'll get their a freedom from on
restraints on the right to do to your
body in your own home
what you want the freedom from
surveillance freedom from from Foreign
Wars all of that which they got from
burn in they'll never get from Hillary
or Donald listen I don't think Gary
Johnson is going to be elected president
by things are getting a lot more votes
than anybody including he has ever
thought he would and that may be the
beginning of a very comfortable place
for an amorphous group of people whose
principal purpose is get the government
off my back run you know one of the most
liberal Supreme Court justices in the
modern era William O Douglas said the
Constitution was written to keep the
government off the people's backs that
will unify millions of people could Ron
Paul have done a better job Ron Paul had
a great charisma time is obviously not
on his side and Gary Johnson just has to
put his finger on a half-dozen buttons
not although all of which are connected
to the idea of personal liberty in a
free society you were talking about
Hillary Clinton before and you were
outspoken in the run-up to the FBI
director James Comey releasing his
recommendation not to prosecute her talk
about it and it's it's not simply you
know it's you're not you hate Hillary
Clinton as a person but what is it about
that situation of her using a personal
email server and then dissembling about
its use and its reach and all of that
and then on top of it like that's her
problem she you know she's a bad actor
in all of that right but what is the
problem with the FBI director coming out
and saying like hey you did all of this
stuff wrong and we're not gonna
recommend prosecution but if it's Judge
Napolitano doing it yeah we would
probably well what's wrong is is this
assaults the rule of law I mean the rule
of law essentially means and no one is
below the laws protections and no one is
above the law's requirements and when
people are prosecuted for having done
far less I can go through a litany of
these with you who are some of those
people well the the Justice Department
prosecuted a 22 year old sailor for
taking a selfie and sending it not
not to Sid Blumenthal where could be
hacked by Russian intelligence mrs.
Clinton's confidant but to his
girlfriend and somehow the FBI got their
hands on this thing and it showed that
behind him behind the selfie was a sonar
screen on on a naval sub
he's facing 20 years in jail a Marine
lieutenant in Anna campement in
Afghanistan sees three al Qaeda guys
dressed as Afghan cops
he quickly emails his superiors to warn
them about him eventually there's a
shootout these three guys start shooting
at Americans and the Americans killed
them he made the mistake of sending the
email up to his bosses on it using his
gmail account rather than his military
so he's facing 20 so that I mean the
government does act against people who
you know have loose lips okay so what is
the significance in both of those it was
an act of extreme carelessness the
phrase that mr. Comey said fairly
described what mrs. Clinton did but it
didn't rise to the level of gross
negligence look at this level when you
are sending top-secret information to
your friend and he's being hacked by
intelligence agencies of governments
that are hostile to us when you are in
the territorial borders of those
countries and you're using an unsecure
mobile device that's extreme
carelessness of the level of gross
negligence but and the real crime here
though then or the real failure is the
FBI or or rather the Justice Department
I mean let's leave aside mrs. Clinton
Hillary Clinton have done this but
what's most worrisome is the larger
institutions of government right the
fact that decisions can be made with
respect to law enforcement based on
politics I column last week I called it
the department of political justice I
mean the Attorney General in a two-week
period said the way to fight terrorism
is with love then she publicly
acknowledged that she had altered an FBI
report in order to create a false
impression of what the investigators in
Orlando learned then she has this meet
with Bill Clinton Bill Clinton himself
at the time was and remains a target of
a federal criminal investigation
involving the Clinton Foundation and
involving whether or not mrs. Clinton
his wife was engaged in public
corruption in order to benefit the
foundation while she was Secretary of
State then to say wow I can't really
make a decision in this case anymore
even though we didn't talk about it Bill
Clinton and I I know the impression
looks bad so I'm gonna go along with
whatever the FBI decides there is not a
single incident in the post J Edgar
Hoover FBI where the FBI is had the
final say they don't work for the the
Justice Department doesn't work for them
they work for the Justice maybe she's
going to reform the Clintons with love
use a little talk I mean one of the
things and I know you are you have
worked on a massive Law Review article
about the function of government is to
guarantee natural law this is a
recurring theme in your work yes talk
about that and why is that
why is that important right now at this
point in history perhaps more than it
was 50 or us
so I start with the proposition is there
any government behavior that is moral
and constitutional in the absence of
consent and from that I argue that yes
just as I can protect my natural rights
if you steal my property I can take it
back from me if you pull a gun on me I
can pull a gun on you if you're stopping
me from exercising my free speech I can
move you out of the way just as I can do
that on my own a government can do that
for me so that's all the government can
morally do absent express consent
so is that by the way is one of the
distinctions between being a libertarian
really and being an anarchist that you
believe that government can be
legitimate yes if if you and I agree
that we will abide by a majority vote of
a particular group whether it's the
voters of the city of New York the
voters of the state of New Jersey the
voters of the United States we can be
bound by it but absent that consent what
right does the majority have to
interfere with my liberties right so the
only thing
majority can do against my will in a
free society is protect natural
liberties so tail me from interfering
with someone else's what is you know
because what is natural Liberty or
because people will fight over that and
some people will say you know coming out
of natural law homosexuality is immoral
it should be illegal and it should be
punished or you know certain types of
other drug use might might fit that I
mean there well how do you define the
what is what convenes natural law the
natural law argument stated briefly is
that our rights come from our humanity
whether you believe from God the Father
or whether you believe we are just the
highest biological events going on to a
planet right now and I saw the way I
think we've been overtaken in the past
couple of weeks by something better but
yeah what is that in evolution just
pokemons go or somehow played although
the kids on the plane were playing and
driving me crazy but anyway those kids
they were interfering you know you had a
natural right to that natural oh yeah
but very interesting about whether the
right to remain silent is a natural
right you and I have a historical hero
together st. Thomas More who actually
was executed for exercising his right to
remain silent and the refusal to sign a
piece of paper that the king is the head
of the church on earth so natural law
presumes that our rights come from our
humanity so let's take homosexuality you
have the natural right to engage in a
physical encounter with any consenting
adult you want under natural law I don't
know the Thomas Aquinas would agree with
this because there was a priest and he
would have taught that all sex outside
of marriage and unto the transmission of
life the traditional Roman Hamrlik
teaching on sex is is illicit but in
terms of whether the government can
Brunner fear with this the government
cannot interfere with the behavior of
consenting adults as long as some third
party is not harmed there are two
origins for that the non-aggression
principle I can do what I want as long
as I don't aggress on somebody's body or
property and the natural law principle
these rights our mind and here here is
where conservatives get this wrong
they're not subject to majoritarian
principles libertarians particularly
natural law libertarians believe that
the tyranny of the majority can be as
destructive to human freedom as the
tyranny of a madman Paul Ryan and Mitch
McConnell those guys think they can
write any law and regulate any behavior
and tax any event and mrs. Pelosi agrees
and it's legitimate just because they do
it
so to go back to the exemplar you're
saying well you know maybe if people in
New Jersey and lord knows they've been
trying they vote in people who say you
know what we're gonna raise taxes and
we're gonna take your money with force
of law at the point of a gun ultimately
if it comes to that and we're gonna
spread it around
what does that contravene natural law
whatever having okay great question it
would only be morally valid if I agreed
at the outset that I would be bound by
what the legislature does or by what the
the voters do I mean do you know anybody
who living was consented to the
Constitution do you know anybody living
who expressly consents
to the existence of the government and
except and incense to what it does my
rights your rights are integral to our
humanity the government can't take them
away by majority vote it's that kind of
just I mean it's not like a law school
argument that I'm saying well you know
what I never signed the Constitution you
know my name is not on it so I'm not
bound by it or you know I vote for I
live in a state I just live in a state
that does certain Jefferson try to leave
Jefferson argued in the Declaration of
Independence that the the only valid
moral government is one produced by the
consent of the government now that's not
just Jefferson's musings that's the
birthplace of the United States of
America if it is Jefferson's musings
then we are all subject to the majority
if it really means something then we are
only subject to the government when we
consent to that but it is and is it but
then how do you have to consent every
day do we have to have like every day
you have to check a box and say yep
today I consent to the government so
I'll pay my taxes that are due today
look when the government takes taxes
from me against my will it is stealing
my property and if I don't consent
to that Jefferson would condemn it so
it's the only moral commercial
transaction is one that is voluntary so
we have in the history of the United
States some great libertarian anti-tax
protesters including Henry David Thoreau
including the poet Allen Ginsberg
including Abbie Hoffman you know where
they would say I'm paying my you know
I'll pick the portion of my tax that
goes to welfare but I don't want it to
go to war or something like that and
actually that was the ROE I mean he was
yes protesting the mexican-american or
listen I love those guys I know that
what's very interactive know what
percentage of your taxes do you consent
to we're not done not it's a hard for me
to imagine something that the government
does that I would consent to doesn't
keep me safe it doesn't even keep me
free it runs schools or their trend it
where they're trying to turn a pig's ear
into was so person I stopped to pay for
these schools it's hard it'd you just
call the children and we're both from
New Jersey so we'll keep it in New
Jersey you're calling kids in New Jersey
pigs ears a lot of like the ones that
we're next to me on the plane out here
or were drinking rum and coke so in the
morning tell me the you know what what
is the alternative okay so you you have
this Law Review article where you lay
out the case how do you that case has
been made since Aquinas since before
Aquinas you can find precursors to it
how do you make that a popular case that
actually weirdly you need a majority of
people to believe in that to vote in the
government that you want
rests upon the idea that you well know
that that's where the left and the right
come together in their love of personal
liberty and their disdain for gumming
government telling them how to live down
I don't know how this is going to happen
I doubt it's going to happen in my
lifetime but if Donald Trump were to
appoint people who think the way I do on
the supreme court and unique discrete
majorities five-to-four here are
different before there were to prevent
the Congress from interfering with
personal liberty or or if if this
attitude became so popular that a
majority of the Congress relieved it was
almost inconceivable because the
government never divest sit self of
power but if that were to happen those
are two ways it could come about
way that this could come about would be
if if the federal government just
collapsed of its own weight its own
indebtedness and the country broke apart
into into discrete smaller governments
or and then finally the biotechnology
revolution and Ron and Rand Paul get
cloned it's a clone as well Nicholas I
trust me if I had a clone I would I'd be
doing a lot more interviews and I'd be
on the beach that's not my clothes that
you're talking to my clone right now
that was a credit test what are the
moments that you're looking forward to
over the next five or ten years where
this position that you're talking about
that you know and it's basically kind of
libertarianism 101 of the government
receding and allowing individuals to
freely engage in whatever they want to
do as long as they're not hurting other
people as I taking people's property or
money what what would be a triggering
event that would help people see the
light of day do you think probably the
financial collapse of the federal
government you know they're the debt is
well will be by the time President Obama
leaves office about twenty trillion
right so that means roughly about a
twenty cents on every dollar collected
but in taxes has to go to address the
debt right now the federal government
can't operate at all without borrowing
about fifty percent of the money that it
needs that it's already committed to
this simply cannot last unfortunately
people who have loaned money to the
federal government are probably the ones
who will lose and there's some very
powerful institutions including the
government of China right which owns a
trillion dollars of our debt so I really
think that the recklessness begun under
Woodrow Wilson exacerbated under FDR
expanded under LBJ and then followed by
every president including the sainted
Ronald Reagan since LBJ extremely
expanded by george w bush over the top
by Barack Obama this debt is out of
control
st. very precious st. Reagan's first
miracle was tripling the national debt
there you go
I mean he had great one-liners and and
and a very appealing personality but he
was just another big government guy of
his version of big government talk and
in a final section here one of the
things that I find fascinating about you
as a kind of theorist of libertarianism
as well as you know a purveyor of it on
television and in your books in your
creators column that we're on of
reason.com it always gets a lot of
response you're also you're very
Catholic a lot of libertarians are
atheists or are hostile to religion and
organized religion and you're us a very
anti-abortion and my guess is that
probably 70% of libertarians are very
pro-choice talk a little bit about the
connection that you see if there is a
necessary connection or if it just
happen it's coincidental between
Catholicism and libertarianism and then
let's talk a little bit about abortion
particularly the Supreme Court's recent
ruling striking down restrictions on
abortion as not quite legit so talk
about kaathal
when we refer to our religion we have to
put a modifier in there
we don't say Catholic we don't say Roman
Catholic we say traditionalist no Roman
Catholic a conservative Catholic wants
to work with the traditional remnants of
Vatican - a traditionalist catholic
wants to reject vatican ii and return to
the teaching of the church which hadn't
changed for 400 years as they existed up
to the time of vatican ii every time I
turn around I am so pleasantly surprised
that the number of libertarians who
refer to themselves a traditionalist
Roman Catholics my opposition to
abortion is not only because of Church
teaching do but also because of a
rational examination of the baby growing
in the womb and a belief in the
non-aggression principle the
non-aggression principle prevents you
from interfering with the life or the
property of another human being without
moral justification there is no
modification for dialing a child on a
well when does but you're also saying to
push back when does you're calling it a
child when does the clump of cells
become a child or is accorded personhood
as a legal concept is
from the moment of conception and then
what is and if it is then that all the
the being in the womb has natural
parents and it has all the actual
izybelle human genome necessary to
produce a Nick Gillespie or a Barack
Obama from that one one could rationally
argue that the protection of the law is
required from the moment of conception
so any well and you see you know that
vision of Catholic theology and it's not
just Catholics as totally consonant with
libertarian ideas yes I do about the
init's about the individual and the
potential of the Inca laws we'll get
back to where we started the only moral
goal and activity of government is to
protect natural rights the greatest
natural right is the right to live the
government's obligation is to protect
that so talk about the Supreme Court
ruling which said in Texas and a bunch
of other states have tried to do this
where they can't pass laws banning
abortion there's a you know Supreme
Court the Supreme Court has ruled that
there is a right to an abortion at least
for the first trimester states have been
trying to get around that by saying okay
you know what you if you run into
bortion clinic you have to you have to
have this kind of procedure in place you
have to have hospital privileges you
have to do this would you agree that
that is that is kind of a backwards way
of doing things of limiting abortion and
in other circumstances what's always
interesting is that conservatives are
like you know you're putting
restrictions and bogus regulations
safety regulations on small businesses
or on businesses that's bad in this case
does the objective overrule the the
means for you you know the Supreme
Court's abortion jurisprudence is is
such a horrific hodgepodge of an effort
to try and find ways to justify abortion
consistent with the Constitution
justice O'Connor in a infamous case
called Casey versus Planned Parenthood
invented a standard called the undue
burden standard meaning whatever the
states do to enhance the health of the
mother and the life of the baby health
of the mother from second trimester on
life of the baby from third trimester on
it can't constitute an undue burden on
the choice the right to choose to have
an abortion come from she just made that
up out of whole cloth and the Supreme
Court has stuck with that it's not used
in any other area of human behavior it's
never been recognized as a standard for
evaluating the behavior of the states
consistent with the Constitution so
Texas now says look we just watch this
awful trial in Philadelphia mm-hmm this
doctor Gosnell who was who was
butchering and slaughtering babies that
were born alive after the abortion we
don't want that to happen here if a baby
comes out alive we want to make sure
there are medical facilities to preserve
the babies light and to preserve the
mother's life so we're going to add
these regulations to prevent that from
happening for the Supreme Court to call
that an undue burden on abortion is
nothing but a political canard intended
to please the left who want to have sex
without responsibility without the
natural consequences of it so well let's
- two quick things should abortion is is
it a federal issue or should it actually
be decided at the state level of
government or a local level well it
depends on on what the government does I
mean the Fifth Amendment prohibits the
government from taking life liberty or
property without due process of law that
has been interpreted to mean that the
government can't permit you or me to
take life liberty or property without
due process of law so if you want to put
that interpretation on it then the
federal government cannot permit that
state to permit abortion for us although
that makes it that also in a weird way
or not in a weird way but in a similar
way to the Commerce Clause that could
open up all sorts of things where really
the federal government calls all the
shots
well if the federal government is
preventing a butcher from killing a baby
that's a good thing for the federal
government today I'm saying is it is it
Aquinas who also came up with the idea
of subsidiarity and what not so the yes
was this is an ongoing challenge for
libertarians at what level how many
levels of government is at what level
right you ready already teaches that the
the smaller the government the closer to
the human beings being governed the
better it is and that that act of
governance should not expand to a higher
and greater level of government except
as is as is necessary on the other hand
the reason we have a a federal
government is to prevent things like
slavery from happening again so if the
states were to look the other way while
pushers destroyed babies in the womb and
the federal government didn't do
anything about it it would be violating
its obligation under the fifth amendment
to make sure that life liberty and
property are not taken without due
process as a final question judge you
had spoken me you are a paragon of
health as you you get healthier as you
get older you told me that every year
you go that's against the laws of
metaphysics but it's nice to hear you go
through a five hour physical in
mid-november so it's gonna be after 2016
within you know twenty to fifty points
is your blood pressure gonna be way up
here or is it gonna be in the normal
range after the election in November you
know I I am pessimistic the one side of
me is very pessimistic that the
Constitution means very very little
other than the establishment of the
three branches of government that the
courts willingly looked the other way
they let the present United States kill
Americans for gosh sakes using drones
the other side of me is optimistic that
young people will eventually say enough
is enough we're just not going to deal
with this we're not going to pay Woodrow
Wilson's debts now I'm making them
probably thirty billion to fight World
War one and the principle has yet to be
paid back we've paid fifteen billion in
interest on that thirty billion of flat
World War one time we just
so the first step is teaching young
people who would row Wilson is that why
the public schools because the public
schools teach listen to Authority I say
challenge Authority and every
conceivable not saying this to Roger
Ailes at every conceivable opportunity
challenge Authority we will leave it
there thank you so much to Andrew
Napolitano as always we have been
talking to Fox News's senior legal
analyst author of many books all of
which should be read Judge Andrew
Napolitano thanks so much Thank You Nico
for a reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie